- Most of us tie our shoe laces wrong.
There are two ways to tie
a knot in your shoe laces.
In one, you go counterclockwise
around the loop,
and in the other, you go clockwise.
These two methods look almost identical,
but one of these knots is
far superior to the other.
It doesn't loosen or come
untied nearly as easily.
To understand why,
we need to delve into knot theory.
This is a whole branch of mathematics
that aims to identify,
categorize and understand
every possible knot that could ever exist.
So far, we have discovered
the first 352,152,252 knots.
Each one has its own
particular properties and characteristics.
I think it's fascinating
that there's something
like a periodic table
for knots out there,
but it's not pure math.
Knot theory has turned out
to be remarkably useful.
It is core to the structure
of proteins and DNA.
It's leading to new materials
that could be stronger than Kevlar.
It's even used to develop medicines
that save millions of lives.
All of this just from trying
to understand the humble knot.
So what is a knot?
Well, in our everyday lives,
we see knots like this or this,
but if you are trying to
rigorously study knots,
you want to be able to pull them apart
so you can really see what's going on.
The problem is knots like
this are held together
only by tension and friction.
So if you pull on them too hard,
they fall apart.
So in order to capture
the knot on the rope,
mathematicians got the idea
to connect the two ends.
And now, well, you can tease
the knot apart to study it,
but it will never fundamentally change.
So in knot theory, all
knots exist on closed loops.
This means the simplest knot you can have
is just a circle like this.
Now, admittedly, this
is not much of a knot,
which is why it is called an unknot.
Here is another knot.
Again, it's made of a single piece of rope
that forms a closed loop.
Here is another.
Two knots are only different
if you can't make one into the other
without breaking the loop.
This is the simplest
knot after the unknot.
It is called the trefoil,
and you can see that there's no way
for me to turn this back into a circle
unless I actually break it open,
take out the knot and
then close it up again.
Now I have two unknots.
It is surprisingly hard to
tell two knots apart by eye.
Here is a simple mystery knot.
Is it an unknot, a trefoil or neither?
I'll give you a second to figure it out.
It is in fact a trefoil,
which you can see if I just untwist this
and rearrange the knot a little bit.
And our first complicated knot,
well, it is actually just the unknot.
I'm going to try to disentangle
it so you can see that.
There you go.
It was just a single loop.
In fact, these are all unknots,
and this is where the problem begins.
You can't just randomly tangle some rope
and connect the ends.
To make a new mathematical knot,
you need to prove
it's not just a tangled up
version of another knot.
So how do you tell two knots apart?
This one question,
also known as the knot
equivalence problem,
is so famously difficult
that it's propelled the
entire field of knot theory
for over 150 years.
Alan Turing even wrote
in his final publication,
"No systematic method is yet known
"by which one can tell whether
two knots are the same.
"A decision problem which
might well be unsolvable
"is the one concerning knots.
"The results in this
article set certain bounds
"to what we can hope to
achieve purely by reasoning.".
Previously, the most famous
knot problem in history
was the Gordian knot.
It was said that whoever untangled
this massive knotted rope
was destined to rule all of Asia.
Legend goes, Alexander the Great
simply came along and
sliced right through it.
That would not be a valid
solution in knot theory.
And there are other
famous knots of history.
The endless knot is seen as far back
as clay tablets from the Indus Valley,
and it was used in
Medieval Celtic designs,
Chinese knot work and
Hinduism and Buddhism.
In Incan civilization,
knots were tied on chords called quipu
to track everything
from taxes to calendars.
You can even find a knot
in the coat of arms for
the House of Borromeo,
an Italian noble family that
has existed since the 1300s.
The Borromeon rings
are technically a link,
which is just a knot with
multiple loops of rope.
The most basic link is the unlink,
two loops which aren't actually connected,
much like the unknot.
After that is the Hopf link.
Then later, the Borromeon rings and more.
But the knot equivalence problem
was only encountered centuries later.
In January of 1867,
Scottish physicist Peter Guthrie Tait
showed off his homemade smoke machine
to renowned scientist William Thomson,
later Lord Kelvin.
Tait had read a paper
that said a vortex ring
should be eternally stable
in an ideal fluid.
So intrigued, he set up two wooden boxes
containing a kind of toxic mixture
of ammonia, sulfuric acid and salt.
When he tapped a towel
stretched across the back of each box,
the chemical smoke popped
out of a circular cutout
in perfect rings.
Kelvin, watching, was
transfixed by the rings.
He had been pondering
the composition of atoms,
a fundamental question of the time,
and suddenly he saw an answer.
He declared that atoms must be made
out of vortex rings of ether,
an invisible everywhere medium.
Different knots of vortex rings
would make different elements.
The shape of the Hopf link
explained the double
spectral lines of sodium.
The simple unknot ring was hydrogen.
Tait was skeptical,
but as Kelvin's vortex model of the atom
became a leading theory,
Tait began investigating knots in earnest.
In his mind,
creating a periodic table of the elements
with every new knot he found.
The crossing number is an
easy way to categorize knots.
Just take the simplest form of a knot,
one with no extra twists or tangles,
and count up all its crossings.
By hand, Tait discovered a three
crossing knot, the trefoil,
then a four crossing
knot, the figure eight,
then two five crossing knots,
three six crossing knots and
seven seven crossing knots.
One quick note, knots are additive.
You can stick multiple knots
together to make a new knot,
like combining these two trefoils
into a six crossing knot.
This is called a composite knot,
but some knots aren't
decomposable into simpler knots.
These are known as prime knots.
Since all composite knots
are just built from primes,
people mainly focus on
tabulating prime knots.
Unfortunately for Tait,
warning signs were on the horizon
for Lord Kelvin's vortex
theory of the atom.
Mendeleev's first periodic table
had been published in 1869.
The Michelson-Morley
experiment sowed seeds of doubt
about an ether in 1887,
and the most damning result
was JJ Thomson's discovery
of the electron in 1897.
So there were particles
smaller than the atom
which were inside atoms.
But Tait was already in too
deep with knots to stop.
He had even roped in his academic rival
and close friend James Clerk Maxwell
of Maxwell's equations fame.
Thanks to Tait's influence,
Maxwell became a knot enthusiast
for the rest of his life.
His last poem
written shortly before his
death from stomach cancer
even begins, "My soul's
an amphichiral knot,
"upon a liquid vortex wrought."
Assisted in part by hundreds
of letters with Maxwell,
Tait published his list
of knots up to seven crossings in 1877,
the first math paper with
the word knots in its title.
Then Tait paused his
search for seven years.
In a speech, he stated,
"The requisite labor increases
with extreme rapidity
"as the number of crossings is increased.
"Someone with the requisite leisure
"should try to extend this list,
"if possible, up to 11."
Two mathematicians took him
up on his call for help,
Thomas Kirkman and Charles Little.
Together, the three of them
were able to find all
21 eight crossing knots,
all 49 nine crossing knots
and all 166 10 crossing knots by 1899,
just two years before Tait's death.
This was all done painstakingly by hand.
Tait admits in his paper,
"I cannot be absolutely certain
that all those groups are
essentially different,
one from another."
In the process of tabulating knots,
he had uncovered the central problem
of how to possibly tell them apart.
Somewhat miraculously,
Tait, Kirkman and Little
had done a near perfect job
with their knot tables.
Their list stood for 75
years without change,
until a single correction in 1973.
But more on that later.
For decades after Tait's death,
little progress was made on
the knot equivalence problem.
But in 1927,
German mathematician Kurt Reidemeister
proved a radical theorem.
You only need three types of moves
to transform any two identical
knots into each other.
The twist, the poke and the slide,
where you move a string
from one side of a crossing to the other.
Now we can prove some knots are the same.
If you can show that they're connected
by Reidemeister moves,
you've proven that they must be identical.
But we still don't know
how to prove any knots
different from each other
because you could do Reidemeister moves
on one knot for centuries
without it ever looking
like the other knot.
And maybe they're actually different,
but maybe they're the same
and you just never made the right move
to show that that is true.
This may have been where
Turing was coming from
when he called the knot
equivalence problem
potentially undecidable.
But in 1961,
mathematician Wolfgang Haken
created a computer algorithm
that solved the not equivalence
problem definitively
for this specific case
of distinguishing any
knot from the unknot.
That said, his paper
was over 130 pages long
and the algorithm would've taken longer
than the age of the universe
to run for large knots.
In 2001, building on Haken's work,
mathematicians found a way
to distinguish between
any knot and the unknot
by simply setting an upper bound
on the number of Reidemeister
moves needed to connect them.
If you check all sequences
of Reidemeister moves
up to that number,
you can prove if the knot
is the unknot or not.
There's just one problem.
That upper bound was two
to the 100 billion n moves.
As of today,
the upper bound has improved dramatically
to just 236 n to the power of 11.
Now, while smaller than before,
checking all possible
sequences of Reidemeister moves
up to this number is still unfathomable.
For a single crossing knot,
this is larger than the number of stars
in the observable universe.
In 2011, mathematicians
found an upper bound
on the number of Reidemeister moves needed
to connect any two knots or links,
solving the entire knot
equivalence problem.
This is the upper bound.
First, raise two to the second power,
then raise that to the power of two again.
This operation is called
tetration, and it grows fast.
Now keep doing it until you
have raised two to itself
10 to the million n times.
Cap it off with n again.
This is easily the largest number
we have ever shown in a video.
But even just to have a
solution is remarkable,
given that Turing thought the problem
was potentially undecidable
only 60 years earlier.
If it's this hard to tell two knots apart,
how have we managed to tabulate
350 million different knots?
Well, there are some properties of a knot
that never change,
no matter how much you
twist or tangle it up.
These are called invariants,
and these invariants will
be different for some knots
compared to other ones.
So you can use them as
hallmarks of a particular knot.
They're not perfectly discriminating.
I mean, some knots will share invariants,
but if two knots have different invariants
then you know for sure
that they are different.
Crossing number is itself aninvariant.
Two knots can't be identical
if they have different crossing numbers.
But the crossing number
is surprisingly difficult to calculate.
You can put extra crossings into any knot,
like just throw in a bunch of twists.
Different variations of the same knot
are known as different
projections of that knot.
Crossing number measures the
least number of crossings
a knot can have,
but it only works for the
simplest projection of a knot,
also known as its reduced form,
but it's difficult to ensure
that a knot is fully reduced.
Instead, we can use another invariant,
one that's true right away
for all projections of a knot.
So it'll give the same value
both for a messy trefoil
and for a reduced trefoil.
This first invariant is tricolorability
or whether or knot can be
colored in with three colors.
Take a diagram of a knot
and color in each individual segment.
These are just separated
by under crossings
where you would lift
your pen off the page.
Tricolorability only has two rules.
First, you must use at least two colors
because you can color any
knot in with one color.
And second, at crossings,
the three intersecting strands
must either be all the same
color or all different colors.
Basically no two colored crossings.
There are just two
categories of this invariant,
either a knot is tricolorable or it's not.
Identical knots must match.
So if one knot is tricolorable
and the other one isn't,
then you know they're different knots.
It's hard to believe that
tricolorability is constant
across any possible
projection of the same knot,
but since you only need Reidemeister moves
to move between projections,
we just need to prove
that it isn't affected
by Reidemeister moves.
The twist is easy.
Everything's one color already,
and it stays that way.
With the poke,
the intersection of two colors
means that the loop formed
must become the third color.
So we have three colors
at every intersection.
With the slide,
you never have to break tricolorability
because you start with three
colors at three intersections
and then switch one
intersection to just one color.
So any knot will maintain
its tricolorability,
no matter what Reidemeister moves you do.
This is a good time to note
that we never actually proved
the trefoil and the unknot
were two different knots,
but we can do it now with tricolorability.
The unknot is not tricolorable
since you can't use at least
two colors to color it in,
and the trefoil is easily tricolorable,
just color in each of the three
segments a different color.
The crossings all have three colors,
so it is tricolorable.
Now we know
every possible projection of
the trefoil is tricolorable
while every possible
projection of the unknot isn't.
So these two knots must
be different knots.
This invariant isn't very specific.
It only gives you two
categories across all knots.
In fact, the next knot after the trefoil,
the figure eight knot, isn't tricolorable.
There's always a crossing with two colors.
So how do we prove that this
is different from the unknot,
which also isn't tricolorable?
Tricolorability expands into
a much more powerful invariant
called p-colorability,
where p can be any prime
number besides two.
Instead of using colors,
we'll number each strand
with integers between
zero and p minus one.
p-colorability has two rules.
First, you must use at
least two different numbers.
Second, at crossings,
the two bottom strands added
together and divided by p
must give the same remainder
as twice the top strand divided by p.
Tricolorability was just
a simple version of this.
If we go from three to five colorability
for the figure eight knot,
we can number the strands zero, one,
and then this strand must give
a remainder of zero, so four,
and this strand must give a
remainder of two, so three.
This knot is five colorable,
so it's not the unknot.
p-colorability is a huge tool.
The unknot is completely uncolorable,
so any knot with any
colorability can't be the unknot.
p-colorability still
doesn't cover everything.
Some of the most powerful
invariants right now,
the ones that can distinguish
between the most unique knots,
are polynomials.
The Alexander polynomial
was the first one discovered
back in 1923 before
even Reidemeister moves.
Like p-colorability,
it relies on only two rules.
The first is that the Alexander
polynomial of the unknot
is equal to one.
The second is that you can zoom in
on any single crossing of a knot
and vary it in three possible positions,
forward, backward and separate.
The Alexander polynomial
gives a relationship
between the three resulting knots.
Let's do an example.
What's the Alexander
polynomial for the unlink?
Well, if we zoom into
this separate crossing
and then vary it,
we see that the other two knots
formed are both the unknot,
so we can plug in one for both of them,
and we get that the Alexander
polynomial for the unlink
must be zero.
Then we can do the same for the Hopf link.
Taking this crossing as
the forward crossing,
then seeing that the backward
crossing gives us the unlink,
and the separate crossing is the unknot.
So the Alexander polynomial
for the Hopf link
is minus t to the 1/2
plus t to the minus 1/2.
And now we can do the trefoil.
When we vary this crossing,
we get that the backward
crossing gives us the unknot
and the separate crossing
gives the Hopf link.
So the Alexander polynomial is t minus one
plus t to the negative one.
The polynomial is designed so
that we get separate results
for as many knots and links as we can,
and this is recursive.
We can calculate the polynomial forever
for bigger and bigger knots.
The Alexander polynomial stood
unchanged for over 60 years
as the knot invariant of choice.
But in 1984,
it was upended by an unlikely discovery.
Mathematician Vaughan Jones
had been working on a type of algebra
for statistical mechanics,
a concept in physics,
when he realized
his work resembled a series
of equations in knot theory.
He traveled to New York
to consult knot theorist Joan
Birman at Columbia University,
who helped refine his equations
into a knot invariant.
They met again a week later
and tested it against knot diagrams
from Birman's filing cabinet,
quickly realizing Jones had discovered
a brand new polynomial invariant.
He scribbled down all their
work in a 15 page letter.
The Jones polynomial
is like the Alexander,
but with the more specific
equation for the second rule
that lets it distinguish many more knots.
For this discovery,
Jones won the field's medal in 1990.
The first new polynomial invariant
kicked up a fervor in knot theory.
Just months after Joan's result,
six mathematicians each independently
found an improved
version of his polynomial
with two variables instead of one.
The editors of the American Math Society
published all their papers together,
naming it The HOMFLY polynomial.
Two Polish Mathematicians missed the news
and discovered it again
a couple months later,
upon which it became the
HOMFLY-PT polynomial.
None of these invariants works alone.
Just like if you were
searching for a person,
you'd start by checking a
first name, then a last name,
then a birthday and so on
to eventually narrow your
search down to just one person.
Similarly, knots have
dozens of invariants,
which when taken together,
uniquely identify them.
With invariants to prove
if knots are different
and Reidemeister moves to
prove if knots are the same,
you can attack from two angles
to meet the gargantuan task
of distinguishing every single knot.
But this method isn't perfect.
These two knots were
listed next to each other
in Tait's knot tables for over 75 years.
They were the same by
all invariant accounts.
So Tait and Little likely
tried Reidemeister moves
to see if they could
transform one into the other.
And once they failed,
they listed them as two separate knots.
Kenneth Perko, a lawyer who
had studied knot theory,
spotted them in 1973
while looking through Little's
table of 10 crossing knots.
Suspicious of their similarities,
he pulled out a yellow legal pad
to sketch some Reidemeister moves,
and he quickly found a way
to connect the two knots.
These two projections now
known as the Perko pair
are the same knot.
So the knot tables of
Tait, Kirkman and Little
were issued their single correction.
And instead of 166 ten crossing knots,
there are 165.
It had taken decades of work
to tabulate all 249 prime knots
up to 10 crossings.
No one dared tackle the 11
crossings until John Conway.
He found all 552,
and claimed he did it
in a single afternoon.
This was the last tabulation by hand.
In the '80s,
Dowker and Thistlethwaite
built a computer algorithm
to count all 12 and 13 crossing knots.
Thistlethwaite later joined
forces with Hoste and Weeks
to tabulate all 14, 15
and 16 crossing knots
in a paper titled "The
First 1,701,936 Knots."
The method they used is
still the one used today,
employing a computer to
list all possible knots
and then using invariants
to weed out duplicates.
They split into two teams
and crosscheck their results,
aligning perfectly on all but
four knots on their first try.
In 2020, mathematician Ben Burton
single-handedly tabulated all
17, 18 and 19 crossing knots,
bringing the total number
of known prime knots
to 352,152,252.
His project was so
computationally intensive,
several hundred computers
had to run for months
before obtaining the final number.
The hardest part of knot tabulation
is counting up every knot
and then carefully eliminating duplicates.
But if you just want to generate
a huge number of distinct knots,
you can make alternating knots,
knots with crossings that
alternate over, under.
This computation is much easier,
though it leaves out most knots.
And back in 2007,
this method was used to
find alternating knots
up to an absurd 24 crossings.
So in total, we know of
159,965,097,353 knots.
Of course, we're missing
a lot in between there.
Knot theory was always just pure math.
All the algorithms,
invariants and tabulations
were knowledge for the sake of knowledge.
But in 1989, chemist Jean-Pierre Sauvage
tied molecules around copper ions
to form the first ever
synthetic knotted molecule.
This trefoil knot restricted
the atoms from unfurling,
trapping them in higher energy states
to give the molecule new properties.
Any type of knot tied in a molecule
will change its properties,
and we know of over 159 billion knots.
So if you can tie a molecule
into each of those knots,
that's 159 billion new unique materials
created from a single molecule.
Though after the trefoil,
chemists have only managed
to tie five other molecular knots to date.
It's a difficult task.
Since they can't just nudge
individual ions into place,
molecules must be built to
self-assemble into knots.
Knot theory helps identify which knots
match available molecular templates,
symmetric knots are easier for one,
and how to arrange those
to assemble the knot.
The most complex knot yet
created is the 819 knot
with 192 atoms tied around
a central chloride ion.
This molecule holds the
Guinness World Record
for tightest knot in the world,
defined as the most
crossings per unit length,
in this case, eight
crossings in 20 nanometers.
Since it's knotted around a chloride ion,
once the ion is removed,
this molecule is one of the
strongest chloride binders
in existence.
The field is still new
for specific applications.
Chemists are just focused
on creating molecular knots
before thinking about
materials development,
but they hope to eventually build things
like durable fabrics stronger than Kevlar.
Knot theory is also critical
to biological processes
that have saved millions of lives.
Bacterial DNA consists of a single loop
of the double helix molecule.
This shape means that it
always forms a knotted link
when it replicates,
and the bacteria can't
separate into two cells
with their DNA tangled up like this.
So they have an enzyme called
type two topoisomerase,
which snips and reconnects the DNA.
This turns their linked
DNA back into an unlink
so they can replicate cleanly.
If you inhibit type two tophi summaries,
the bacteria can't replicate properly,
and in fact they die.
This is how some of the most
common antibiotics in the world
called quinolones operate.
Human DNA, while not circular,
is long enough to also get into tangles.
Each cell in your body
contains two meters of DNA.
That's the equivalent
of stuffing 200 kilometers of fishing line
into a basketball.
When this mess inevitably tangles,
human type two topoisomerases
come to make crossing changes.
The human version of the
enzyme is different enough
from the bacterial version
that it's unaffected by antibiotics.
But human topoisomerases
are sometimes intentionally inhibited.
This stops replication and kills cells,
predominantly the rapidly
dividing cancer cells.
So it's one of the most
common forms of chemotherapy.
Biologists needed knot theory
to first understand the mechanism
of type two topoisomerase.
Once they observed
it was decreasing the crossing
number of knots in DNA
two at a time,
they realized it had to
be cutting and rejoining
entire double strands of DNA.
And there are many other
obscure topoisomerases
that act on DNA.
Knot theory is used
to analyze the knots they tie or untie
and how they operate as a result.
It's not just DNA that knots.
1% of all proteins have various knots
in their fundamental structure.
If they get misknotted, they malfunction.
So being able to
accurately tell knots apart
helps understand these
proteins' mechanisms,
as well as how to potentially
repair or utilize them.
When it comes to your shoe laces,
both of the common ways to tie the knot
are composed of two trefoils
on top of each other.
I'm going to tie some rope around my leg
to make this easier to see.
When you go counterclockwise
around the loop,
well, then you form two identical trefoils
on top of each other.
This is also known as a granny knot.
But when you go clockwise around the loop,
then you get mirror imaged
trefoils on top of each other.
This is also known as a square knot,
and it doesn't loosen as easily.
So we should all be tying
our shoelaces like this,
clockwise around the loop.
Most of us aren't.
I mean, I'm not, usually.
I normally do it like this.
A simple overhand knot
is just the trefoil.
The bow line knot,
the most common knot for boating
or just holding things
together is the six two knot.
And any knot tied without using the ends,
also known as in the bite,
that is just an unknot.
So a slipknot is an example of an unknot.
In 2007, researchers Dorian
Raymer and Douglas Smith
conducted 3,415 trials of
spinning string in boxes
to study how knots form in the real world.
They ended up creating 120
different types of knots,
some as complicated as 11 crossings.
They found that longer agitation time
led to a higher chance of knotting.
Longer string did as well,
except this probability decreased
once the string was put in a smaller box,
which restrained its motion.
So if you want to keep
something like headphones
from knotting in your pocket
where you can't adjust string
length or agitation time,
then your best bet is to confine them
to as small a space as possible.
Raymer and Smith also proposed a model
for real world knot formation.
A series of loops are first formed
when a string is placed into a container.
Then when it's agitated,
a free end of the string
gets woven up and down through the loops,
braiding itself into them to form knots.
And let's see, a knot.
So coiling up your wires
is actually setting
yourself up for failure
because you're forming a bunch of loops
for a loose end to braid
perfectly into a knot.
So instead, what you want to
do is restrict its movement,
whether by using a small box
or increasing string stiffness.
DNA increases its
stiffness by super coiling,
and you can do the same with your wires.
I just double it up like this,
and then I twist from the middle.
And this is going to
stiffen the length of wire.
Now, this is naturally
going to want to sort of coil in on itself
and it's going to look
like a big tangled mess,
but all you have to do
is take the opposite ends of
the headphone and pull apart,
and there's no tangles, no knots.
Their study won an Ig Nobel Prize.
It has been cited in studies
of knots in surgical catheters,
and even linked to an Apple
patent for stiffer earbud wires.
Knot theory began as a
failed theory of everything,
and for the next century,
it was a standalone field of math
propelled by nothing more
than intellectual curiosity.
But in recent years, it's
reclaimed its original potential.
Today, knot theory
is a theory of everything
from headphone tangles
to material science to chemotherapy.
In 1889, Kelvin gave
a presidential address
to the British Institution
of Electrical Engineers
about his failed atomic theory of knots.
"I am afraid I must end
"by saying that the
difficulties are so great
"in the way of forming anything
like a comprehensive theory
"that we cannot even imagine a finger-post
"pointing to a way that leads
us towards the explanation.
"But this time next year,
"this time 10 years,
"this time 100 years,
"I cannot doubt
"but that these things which
now seem to us so mysterious
"will be no mysteries at all,
"that the scales will fall from our eyes,
"that we shall learn to look
on things in a different way
"when that which is now a difficulty
"will be the only common sense
"and intelligible way of
looking at the subject."
Knot theory is a perfect example
of how knowledge in one area
can become a tool to
understand countless others.
From learning how to tell a
trefoil apart from an unknot,
knot theorists have built all the way up
to discovering brand new proteins.
If you want a quick and easy way
to build out your own mental toolkit,
you should absolutely check
out this video sponsor,
brilliant.org.
Brilliant is the best way to
learn about almost any concept
in math, data science,
programming and more.
They even have a
computational biology course
where you can apply
concepts from this video
to folding protein chains.
With Brilliant, you just set your goal
and they'll design the
perfect learning path
to help you reach it,
equipping you with professional
tools along the way.
Want to harness the tools
of a data scientist?
Brilliant's newest course
Predicting with Probability
is the best place to get them.
The course has everything you
need and nothing you don't
to start building your
data science skills.
There is no coding required.
You'll learn easily to slice
and dice massive data sets,
compare distributions and
master fundamental concepts
like Bayes' theorem,
all while working with
real air traffic data.
You'll learn to answer questions
like which airlines have the
least delays due to weather
and how much more unruly
passengers have gotten since the pandemic.
Data skills are absolutely necessary
to navigate our world today.
And Brilliant is the
best place to get them.
Beyond their data courses,
Brilliant also has a
massive content library,
all of it highly visual, interactive,
and incredibly easy to understand.
It's more than just a learning platform.,
it's your path to understanding the world
of math, data and computer science.
By learning on Brilliant,
you'll always be one step ahead
as technology and the modern
world advances every day.
To try everything Brilliant
has to offer for free
for a full 30 days,
visit brilliant.org/veritasium.
I will put that link
down in the description,
and the first 200 of you to sign up
will get 20% off Brilliant's
annual premium subscription.
So I want to thank Brilliant
for sponsoring this video,
and I want to thank you for watching.